point is some if you have respect for  somebody so for example if I have if I'm  with a guy that we respect each other  but we don't have to be in a possessive  relationship where it's like you're mine  and I'm yours no I want it to be a case  of for example we have a baby and every  single day we communicate you can come  over my house I can come over to yours  the baby will grow that he lives there  Mommy lives here you can go to Daddy's  house  you've got a better chance grabbing one  of the guys in the friend zone and  having a kid with him because you know  them you're friends with them and having  a relationship with them listen you've  got literally probably zero percent  chance meeting a guy fresh and being  like hey I know we just met but let's  have a kid no I wouldn't do that